does an hour have knowledge that you can
know it by you said nine the Adamas root
and Muslims have to know these signs so
they recognize them when they see them
and there are many signs one of the
signs yaku Nevada do haze' children
become filled with rage when yakunin
mother Ojeda rain becomes burning or
acidic acid rain once a field that a
shot will fail that you'll see evil
people spreading widely that the dishes
will be communicating continuously and
the Prophet used the very word that's
used for satellite communications you
all saw that and people will sever their
family time in other words people will
stay home and watch television on
satellite dish and they won't go visit
their neighbors this is an amazing
hadith to me greetings of peace welcome
to the D show we have an exciting
episode as we always do subscribe right
now so you can get to deliver directly
to you you've heard these terms
Armageddon
people talking about World War 3
Antichrist
Mathi signs of the Day of Judgment now
this topic is a hot topic is very
exciting and I just want to make a
disclaimer and point out that in no way
these are things that are mentioned in
the Bible these are things from the
Islamic tradition and we want you to be
educated on what Islam has to say about
the day of judgment the signs of it and
some of these other terms like
Armageddon is this Islamic term what
does it mean Antichrist it is actually
anti Islam to be anti carte you're gonna
be learning so much and more remember I
Salaam it advocates peace and justice so
in no way when we talk about many of
these things this is putting things out
there for education but in no way does
this advocate for any violence this is
something that we're presenting these
topics and the essence of education to
see the Islamic perspective compares
someone with the Bible so you can be
enlightened look more into it and that's
what we have to talk about on this
week's show don't go anywhere a very
exciting topic we'll be right back you
will see hypocrites ruling well
Kulu silken food Jawa and you will see
the worst people controlling the
marketplaces yeah I'm gonna miss rune
any minute and I'm aside Yashiro Pia and
Sousa - Maha d12 horrible kuru you will
have automated masks but the hearts
would be ugly for people praying in the
mosque they done noticed here but the
mask is beautiful what are some of the
signs of the day of judgement you have
minor major let's talk about some the
edge holders broke down the signs of the
owl based on the hadith into minor and
meter those are main categories the
minus signs are signs that already
happened when ended and they will never
happen again
like the sending of the prophets allah
salla like the death of the prophet
sallallaahu lashana like that leg of
hamas that happened around the 24th
after he died will be consider major
sign or my no no minor and I'm cat and
cat I'm sub sobbing the minor signs
signs that happened and they will never
happen again because they are done
science that happened and they keep
happening but they happen in a greater
magnitude like adultery is growing
usually is growing killing is growing
earthquake it happened initially started
but now with the magnitude the more you
approach the hour the more you need the
magnitude t that the greatness of their
happening it can you say these are
prophecies being fulfilled absolutely
yes actually a lot of these scholars
with the fact that the minor signs are
almost done this would be also more you
can add this is proof of profitability
see this is why we should study it yeah
you know people normally have you know
trading for knowing the unseen so
instead of going to the Chinese
restaurant and reading the fortune
cookie you can read hadith individual as
a level that what would happen in the
future inshallah and yes it affirms your
face your Eman in a way when you see
that something that was foretold years
back and and you see it happening with
your own eyes now number three science -
science which did not happen yet like
the afraid is disclosing a gold amount
of gold that people will kill one
another for it but there is one sign
which the school
give it a very special name that sign is
called the transition of time which is
the emerging of an imam for the muslim
for the muslims golden imam muhammad did
not delay he'll marry and fall to me and
has illallah we al Husseini this one guy
right now he's actually people to see I
myself want to reveal something that I
myself is demanding and I am giving you
the goodness of the arrival of the Jesus
Christ yeah this guy's is this the guy
that we're talking about no no no if
you've had a lot of people come up with
and make this rule our history we had a
lot of claimants
yeah often amantha we and a lot of
people actually claim that they are
Jesus I mean I'll never forget this day
I was a Manning and I'm a CNN and and
Maryland PGA is called and one day two
brothers actually entered into my office
and this is how they introduce
themselves
Salaam alaikum Imam this is Jesus Christ
and Amal Imam Muhammad did not deny him
and it was this Halloween as a joke
actually was this serious about that
serious so he got these claimants and
you remember years back yet we got a lot
of people killed in Harlem because of
somebody who claimed it so we have a lot
of claimants awful matawaia and there is
a reason for that you know the people
who playing it normally you know when
you read this hadith about ill Maddie
you find the Muslims are in control the
Muslims are conquering the Muslims are
in United and when you look at the
condition of the Muslims now it's it's
it's it's disgusting and sorry to say
that it's very sad and when the people
see that the future is very bright but
meanwhile the present is it's very you
know it's very bad
so people attempt to okay mady's going
to bring the change then why do we have
to wait then I'll become a little Maggie
and then bring that she's and work like
it doesn't work like that you know in
allah la ilaha illa allah does not
hasting things to happen because of
people hastening them everything happens
because of a time we got a lot more time
a very hot and interesting topic will be
right
well anywhere we'll see homosexuality
and lesbianism widespread and he said
you will see medical sugan young people
having massive wealth like the
Zuckerberg is a multi-billionaire before
he was 30 and you will see more I'm
attorney Sam you'll see movements to
corrupt the women back here on the Dean
show now
World War three would this have anything
connected with signs of the hours a day
of judgment by the way I want to say
something Eddie that Muslims were not
promoting this it's a big talk
unfortunately here in the Western world
after the fall of Russia they started
saying this they started saying that the
next enemy is Islam and Muslims and and
and they are bringing this up yeah and
subhanAllah always Hollywood is a
reflection of what takes place lately we
actually saw movies called armed
pictures called Armageddon Independence
Day and they talked about the same exact
subject when the attacks in France
happened actually the Pope in Italy said
this is an event which will lead to
World War three he actually made that
statement I'm not making this up the
Pope in Italy so as Muslims were not
really promoting this we're not
propagating this so as the brothers
don't understand that were sitting here
and then and then trying to previous
people for war or anything no we're not
doing that but this is something that is
up there and and in the front and you
need to know the Islamic perspective on
the subject because they have their own
story we do have our own version of the
story we were first told this by the
prophet sallallaahu lesson so we said
the mind of science the last one is
called the transitional sign which is
the emerging of Imam Mohamed Abdullahi
Mahdi again according to a national Yama
because she is lamb they have their own
version of this is somebody who is an
eternal since the thousand years more
than 1200 years almost there that that's
not our Ahmadi our almighty is from one
from the
family of the prophet sallallaahu Selim
who will come and will lead Muslims and
unite them again and he will be the
leader of the Muslim army in this battle
called Armageddon
he's from the offspring of the prophets
allah jalla and just to show the
brothers and because there are some
muslims out there who use intellect they
believe that intellect takes precedence
over divine let up
they see that's not correct you know
that's not true that's you know that
that's not real they and they go after
the hadith and and and so forth and see
that's in this one that's not mentioned
in the Quran and and all that stuff you
know look at that the greatest fitna
earth will ever experience is what the
fitna fought in the jet the worst fitna
that will always gather the Antichrist
so what would be some of the major signs
now today well the major signs is but I
was trying to finish one one in one
point here that the prophets Allah said
I mean one hadith he says if there is
only one day left in this dunya
Allah will prolong it until one of my
progeny from his name is similar to my
name Mohammed Ahmed his father's name is
similar to my father's name who will
come and lead the Muslims and he will
fill earth with justice and peace after
it has been filled with injustice and
and Jona for every human being one yes
yes he yes yes that's why we're talking
about it now he is called a transitional
fine because when he comes we believe
actually the Antichrist will come and
Jesus peace be upon him will descend we
actually believe that he is going to be
in Jerusalem leading the Muslims in
Salah but they say look I've in me to
cut you off but our brothers in humanity
say no you aren't you guys the
Antichrist you Muslims later that
actually it's the vinegar been told that
have you ever heard that can I tell you
something about this yeah and you really
need to dig deep into yourself as I'm
saying this and you'll understand what
I'm trying to say the prophet
sallallaahu Oliver seldom wound us again
is the Antichrist again I'm using the
term even though it's not an Islamic
term it's really the Islamic term isn't
that jet
huh and when he warned us against it the
gel the Antichrist he need one beautiful
statement you know what he said Elano a
new commander owner of the contract at a
motel - I'm a Muslim it is - sure that
you will never be able to see Allah
until you die now who believes that
Allah can come down into earth go into a
womb of a woman and be bored and walk
around people in Earth huh and actually
you take him and put him to the cross
and kill him and spit on him who
believes that now when the Antichrist
come because what is the Antichrist is
going to do when he comes down when he
comes out what is he gonna do when he
comes out of his Island what is he going
to do he's gonna tell people I'm Allah
now the first way to refute the
Antichrist the fact that I'm able to see
you and I'm sorry I'm pointing at you
the fact that I'm able to see you
Antichrist that means you're alive
because if you were truly Allah I
shouldn't be able to see so the be
Antichrist is to be anti Islam Ronnie
Crusader yes so it's a foolish statement
yet and and and this is actually one of
the best ways to protect yourselves
again it's falling into the fitna of the
Antichrist is know the names and the
attributes of Allah subhanAllah looks
upon Allah when you look at somebody
Eddie the first thing that you attract
is the eyes right the eyes of the
individual basically I mean if you're
looking at the same gender so okay we
have to be careful here we're all trying
to get married well I have the real a
fella we're not gonna go there yeah it's
just so look at this now allah subhanaw
taala cools the antichrist to have a
defect in his eye
actually both eyes are defect they do
have defective defective and this is
rubber English both eye one of them is
like a floating gray agreed and the
other one is like you know is there is a
piece of flesh around it why
if you truly truly Allah and you're
giving me good eyes and you have these
eyes go fix your eyes man that that
doesn't make you a lot so but yet when
he comes back and Allah who is going to
allow him to have all the
powers that he will be held by jinn and
he will travel earth with with that
speed guess who's going to follow him
the table who possess the corrupt belief
system once it comes to Allah Subhanahu
Zama alright add to this most of his
followers will be amongst the people who
are awaiting for a messiah somebody who
comes in and basically establishes them
in earth and you can see that a lot of
people they are fake healers people
inviting people in the name of Jesus
Rahim of even some goals from spirits
and you have people throwing their money
out of them they making these claims you
see it's happening and happen other day
yeah he enters this hotel conference
room in Hartford Connecticut with a
security team that rivals a head of
state and a drawing audience greets him
with calls of daddy-o and sees his
praises
he is 60 year old ho Santa Rita his
Miranda from Puerto Rico a preacher and
evangelist to go sure but to his
followers and in his own eyes he's more
than a man of God just ask em um Jesus
Christ men in front of you that's right
he says he is the second coming
people actually the gel is going to come
and cut one of the young men in ladino
comes out we read in Holly say before I
go that is little bihari or Muslim that
hangman will come out of Medina he will
break him into two halves and he's going
to walk in between his two hands and now
the people are doing it now imagine a
CRA because we're going to take a break
right back and well you will see the
destruction of civilization you will see
the civilization of the destruction of
the world so carava dunya that will
become the tamia
it stood near yellow Masaru denim and I
Thomas a Jewish a mafia and tougher
images that musical incidents will be
widespread
Nerissa for our rules the IMP imagine
musical instruments will be on their
heads how did he know about that
that's what it says I didn't make that
up it says now have massive Ottawa lose
the imagine on their heads or musical
instruments who would have thought that
we want to know what that meant at the
time of our profits allotted to them but
now we see it all these people
everywhere welcome back to the D show
now let's get our everybody decided to
know what are some of these these major
signs the major signs are ten and they
are coded in one hadith hadith so they
said Noah see there's a fairy above your
loved one and the hadith is highly non
Muslim the Prophet sallallaahu Hari you
are you a cell then one day he entered
the machete found the Companions are
studying he asked them what are you
studying he said we're studying the hour
o Messenger of Allah he said so la la
jolla felon it will not come until you
sit and science before it and he needs
the Beast the smoke the Antichrist
Dajjal again we're using the word just
for the because it's commonly used
usually a said that the sending of
prophet ISA alaihi salatu wassalam
garden Magog those are five then the Sun
rising from the West
those are six and three landslides one
in the east like earthquakes major
earthquakes one in the east one in the
West and one in the Arabian Peninsula
and the last one which is the ten one a
fire which will erupt out of Yemen will
dismiss people to their place of
gathering now the scrollers do not know
the sequence of this ayat of this major
science a result of Elam did not
indicate the sequence actually there is
another hadith for the same narrator in
Sahih Muslim when he narrated those when
he mentioned those ten but in a
different sequence than the one that I
just quoted
so now modulus Kalani the author of fact
he'll bury the one who explained Fat
Albert half of the goggle he actually
brought them down he said there are two
sets of science the first set was going
to start with basically the Antichrist
breaking out of the IDA the first of the
time and that will lead to profit
because who's going to kill the
Antichrist prophet H alehissalaam that
is going to lead to prophet ISA coming
down and to earth and killing the
Antichrist and googan Gog and Magog you
Joe Matthews will brief bhai
in the woods so those are three then
profitless Ali Salaam would establish
the Sharia and earth and he will rule
out of Jerusalem for years and his
impact will carry on actually the
Prophet sallallahu wasallam said to
evaluation bad Elma see what a good life
will be when the Messiah is actually
ruling using Islam and Sharia out of
Jerusalem identify for the from some
people they're here Sharia and you know
they say you know what you actually
don't know when we go to these debates
with non-muslims Christians in
particular and then they come up with
this issue that you know you guys are
here to establish the Sharia so you know
just to make fun of the whole thing with
it we're not worried about that actually
believe that prophet is that what was
going to come and establish this area so
that is divine God the Creator today
they look at you like you crazy you're
coming out of the musha's yeah it's
really terrific
Jesus more 10 commandments in Syria yeah
yeah that's what the philosophy Sharia
Jesus called clear bigoted
think not look at Matthew 5:17 think not
that I came to abolish the laws and the
prophets but I came to fulfill them and
that's what it is you know sue Sharia
are because I think not that I have come
to abolish the the Sharia there I came
to fulfill it Sharia that's what he's
good at I do yeah that's a that's a
that's what ASA will come come down to
do you see it is hadith in guarding in
Imam Muhammad Nabeel and Madi you see in
that morning a look at the sea now the
Antichrist the gel is out there with
that huge army and the few Muslims the
believers are out there with the dynamic
market there is no way they can even
fight him that the Antichrist
so the social Solomon and Hadees Bukhari
rasul'allah Lhasa and tells us in that
morning near a man is about to lead the
salah and he will look behind and you
will spot prophet s Alice and I'm
walking into a national AXA he will say
dr. Damiano holla Oh spirit from Allah ,
leader since Allah he will say no I'm
not here to lead it was already
established for the ambulance
this is really symbolic that I'm not
here to bring any new laws or any more
I'm here to fulfill the laws that are in
existence and this is the nature of the
second coming of prophet ISA alaihi
salatu salam how do you know because we
covered earlier people making the claims
that they are like the person coming in
your office so what is the criteria how
does a mammal Mandy that is one criteria
basically he's going to be given the
pledge between the Blackstone and the
station of the brahim by Naraku Alma
come now when the evil forces find out
that he is already leading the Muslim
world an army will come from Iraq Syria
that direction
look at this now I'm Subhan Allah this
army will be miraculously swallowed by
earth earth will swallow that army no
but no no for such a huge army then
every Muslim should know that this is
Imam Muhammad Nabeel a man
after the city by the way I want to tell
you something if somebody claims that
he's Almighty this is in itself refused
that he is nothing buddy because we know
from the biography we'll Maddie that he
will be forced in he's going to say no
key stay away from me I am NOT
interested I don't want this know it
come on help us I'm not interested so
they are actually going to force him in
so if you come and claim it that means
then it's like it again if I'm able to
see you in this world because if you're
truly Allah I shouldn't be able to Allah
Allah Allah the dunya in them in fact
this is itself refute the fact that it
you see many similarities when from the
bible and christians there will go
because the aim thing there it's a drama
doesn't match but but but he did hit is
the confusion because they believe that
jesus died we believe the Jesus did not
die Jesus was raised up alive to Allah
subhana WA Ta'ala body and soul
untouched one a potato vomits allahu wa
lakin - but do you crucified Him that
they killed him not but it was made to
appear to them so but withal not because
they believed that he died and he rose
from the dead of course they believe
that when he returns he was gonna return
in the here
that when the day of judgement in here
yeah no yeah we as Muslims we believe
that he is a fine that will come before
the day of judgment so many of these
things are also there in the Bible that
there but again because they messed up
the you know they they did things we
have changed the alleged crucifixion
they had to change the underst the
context of these so they made it what
that he's going to come and raise the
dead then he's going to be the judge in
the day of judgment but for us Muslims
know he's going to come before alia
salatu salam prophet i said before as a
sign of the hour and he's going to live
and actually he's going to go and
perform hajj and umrah on one of them
and he's going to be buried in earth and
after him will be years years of
actually good life in earth and then the
other set of the major signs the sun
rising from the west and the beast will
introduce themselves again and this will
lead to the end of the world let's end
with this where we got one minute left
when same thing when Jesus was asked
about the day of judgment he didn't know
he didn't know yeah obviously he wasn't
God because God is all-knowing we were
very clear but he had called people to
prepare for that day absolutely and then
the same thing about Mohammed listen
with this when he was asked about the
day when it was he said what have you
prepared yes so how can we get people
how can people prepare for that day what
do they need to be a team man hey okay
Eman faith you see you need to
understand this when these major signs
emerged there is hadith mahalia muslim
hadith of allah Rabia lon
sell a certain either halogen three
major signs when they come out if you do
not have Iman faith already established
faith according to a national Jamar
which is the belief of the heart the
uttering of the tongue and the action of
the limbs not faith according to more
general Howard you know that fee fie fie
fie fie you know faith fits the Sahaba
faith of the Rasul of Allah Salim not
fit like you say that my heart is white
and then look can we say the same face
the same pure monotheism yeah Jesus and
his companions are likewise Moses and
his crying why's that believing it and
Muhammad and his compare absurdly so the
same tradition yes pure monotheism pure
monotheism this is the first thing which
is going to save you this is number one
because when a resourceful am named III
say it did gel the Antichrist it dad
that
East and the Sun rising from the West
when these three signs come out if
you'll not have faith already it's over
actually we read that after these major
signs or when these major signs before
the Sun rising from the West and Allah
will no longer accept ogen Allah
actually will send a soft wind to
suffocate the believers to make them die
to relieve them from the kitten and the
worst of mankind will be in the face of
this earth when the hour arrives when
the hour comes Allah for Allah and the
Prophet assalam says let Akuma say
unless you are eNOS the hour will take
place while the worst of mankind are in
the official reserve they are committing
adultery in the streets they are
worshipping idols again and this is when
the cub actually will be disassembled
like that a brick by brick mansion all
these details are there in Islam oh yeah
is not a believable message of both just
tested to this day preserved unchanged I
have one week like you that you find
Muslims going and reading these soap
operas and reading these hurts hearsay
novels and they leave the Quran and the
Sunnah alright we have a lot to learn
thank you for sharing this is alignments
with us Allah it so I'm like a piece of
subtle [ __ ] there you have it the
Islamic perspective on some of these
topics were really stuck in my mind was
being anti-christ is actually being anti
Islam because Jesus he promoted and he
taught Islam what is Islam Islam is to
surrender to submit yourself not to
anything in creation but to the one who
created creation to God Almighty and
everything say Allah and you will see
that when you study the life of prophet
muhammad peace be upon him and the
things that he had foretold you know the
crowd is a living miracle has scientific
facts has so many things that don't go
against science that actually are
verifiable and there
coincide with many discoveries that
we've made today and then there are
other things that the problem of Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon them had foretold
and we see that many of these things
have happened because whatever a prophet
a true messenger says it's definitely
something that will happen and we see
that people such as Aristotle
and others who have made vague
predictions about certain things they
for example make a hundred predictions
and 99% are totally false but the one
that maybe they got right it fits people
forgot about all the 99 other 99 that
are totally false with a true messenger
that sent from the crater they all have
to be a hundred percent correct so until
now everything that we've seen anyone
sincerely studies the life of prophet
muhammad peace be upon him he brought a
believable message which was to what to
what look be sincere with yourself look
to worship the create or not the
creation everybody digs that it's very
simple and then the ones who are calling
us and showing us how to implement that
were those prophets that were sent and
they had told people to prepare for the
day of judgement they gave the signs on
what to expect and we're seeing those
things rapid today adultery fornication
killing all of these in just evils that
are happening but how can you prepare
for it Jesus didn't know when that day
was coming but you have a lot of these
these shysters out there predicting same
things but if Jesus didn't know Muhammad
didn't know they weren't gods but they
were messengers of God and they taught
us how to prepare for the Day of
Judgment by what proper belief pure
monotheism connecting yourself your
heart to the Creator that happens on
earth and obeying him doing all the good
that the Creator told you to do and it's
all packaged in Islam it's very simple
its straightforward it's something that
doesn't go against reason or common
sense
call us
[Applause]